people for whom politics is primarily 1 aesthetic issue
these moments are very interesting
for people who expect nothing from politics
confirms in the image of the hassle of The Hague
with which most people have nothing at all
and for people who expect something from politics
this kind of hague stuff is terrible
it must be about solving
of people's problems
last night and I was just referring to this last night
we had 1 debate
about the recovery operation of 1 allowances scandal
what 1 new scandal is in the making
tonight we have people here in the bath
who put their companies in the cardboard and papers
close industry
and thus see their job and opportunity disappear
and tomorrow we have here in the bath
about abolishing the deductible
where this room
can seize the last chance
to put this in 1-1-2025 to be able to arrange
and the elections were 4 months ago
ordered from the cabinet
Rutte is Rutte 4 is 9 months ago
for more
the parties indicate 1 new cabinet around the summer
to want
then our country has been without a cabinet for 1 year
and that too is not necessarily 1 big problem for the sp
but if there is no cabinet to rule
then the room must take the lead
and it's time for people's problems
in The Place of the problems of formation and police
are going to be solved